Please welcome father and son Odd Nerdrum and Øde Nerdrum!
Welcome!
First of all, because I have father and son here now ...
I thought I would start with a painting ...
... that you've painted, Odd.
And it's a painting we can see here, which is called The Life Saver.
And this is the beginning ...
It's based on the beginning of your story.
What is this painting about, Odd?
Yes, well it was ...
It happened that Øde became seriously ill.
He was infected by his brother, from kindergarten.
And after three-four weeks he was so sick that he had to ...
... go to the doctor. The doctor thought he would live through it and then ...
... he became paler and paler and in the end he was ...
He almost looked like a waxed candle, in the face.
I was away, and when I got home I could see that he was dying.
I finally, thank God, got a hold of the private hospital where we were members.
And in the end, after a lot of commotion ...
... I got them to come over. And when he saw him then, he said that Øde was almost dead.
And Øde died in ...
... the car that drove with sirens up to the hospital.
He died then. And he was dead for a while.
And he got to the hospital, and they started saving him.
He was in a car with a doctor?
Yes, with a doctor from the private hospital.
So ... So the case was that ...
He was dead for quite a period of time.
And when he later was baptised, I said that ...
In the speech ...
That he had been by the land of the dead.
And I was very interested in what he would tell us about that later in life.
I remember one time I was going on a trip with a show called Gutta på Tur.
And then he absolutely wanted to come fetch me at this place where there was a sailboat that was coming to get us.
And that's when I really understood ...
... that our friendship had begun.
Before that, he was a baby ...
... who made strange faces at night.
And I was very worried that he was damaged from that incident.
And ...
Because it is horrible if something happens like that.
And that is what I was always worried about, something happening, and it started ...
But we, thank God, found out that it was Tourettes.
Which you also have?
Yes, I have had a quite severe case of Tourettes, but I've managed to keep it contained ...
... for the most part.
But it doesn't go away, it turns into OCD instead.
And that means that I get a lot of anxiety for people, and for crowds.
I'm not anxious here, because here, I'm in control.
But in a crowd, it doesn't turn out well.
Øde, everything went well with you?
Yes.
And now you're sitting here. And you've done a documentary ...
... about your father.
Yes.
And you've done this together with your brother?
And there are six episodes, and he's not in it.
No, he's not in it, that's the whole point.
Why is that the whole point?
Well ...
The strange thing, especially with Norwegians, is that they ...
... they don't appreciate what a person has done before he has died.
While he's still alive, they just bother him.
But when he dies, they will suddenly notice that he did something, right.
And that's the focus we want.
So you're making a documentary as if he no longer was alive?
Yes, you could say that. Or ...
It's a respect to his work.
So in that way ...
It's about his art and not about him.
Yes. You could say that.
Well, it is about him, but not in a way where we shove the microphone up his face and command him to answer.
It is ...
It is a hunt. So the title is The Hunt for Nerdrum.
What's the most important ...
... thing you've learned from Odd?
The most important thing I've learnt ... It might be that ...
... that I can choose what time I want to live in.
That I don't have to settle for the present.
What do you mean with that?
You're thrown into a time, like we're thrown into the 21st century, right?
If we were thrown into the 16th century, what would we do then?
Would we perhaps be completely different?
And the ... The point is that you don't get to choose when you live.
And I've learnt from my father that I can study history, and I can choose a time period that I'm happy living in.
It's like acting, it's what we do!
Yes. And then I can live like that, right.
It's not only how you dress ...
It's also how you act, and how you deal with moral questions.
So people who study history are less prejudiced because they have a wider perspective.
And it's this perspective ...
What time period do you live in, then?
I haven't quite reached a conclusion. But I know I'm not living in the present time period.
So do you agree on what time period you are in?
Yes, most of the time.
I'm quite smitten with the Age of Rococo.
But my father perceives that as a perfumed parody of a time period, so ...
So there are some disagreements. But we agree that the present is ...
... that we shouldn't settle for the present, at least.
But does that mean that ...
Do you live completely cut off from everything ...
... modern, as much as you can?
Or are you on Facebook?
No.
I haven't been part of that adventure.
Because I know that that is a tiny fish pond.
And in there there are a few small goldfish.
And those are the ones that are Facebook users.
It's a small little world.
And while they themselves think that they are speaking to the world, they are in reality just speaking to a small goldfish pond.
Has he, while you were growing up, done any of the usual father-like things ...
... do you go on holidays, for instance?
No, we don't go on holidays.
Holidays are for the lower classes, I learned that early.
It's at least very tiring!
Yes.
They only do it to feel like they can afford it.
No, that ...
Has he been a, and Odd, you're now going to sit here and just be the object ...
Has he been a father who has attended parent meetings, for instance?
Uh, no.
No, he has done everything else, but not parent meetings.
But all the other things?
Yes.
So in that sense, he has also been a regular father?
Yes, or I can't ... I guess so!
That's not something I can answer, because I wasn't ..
I don't really relate to my childhood in that way.
I got to know him more in my teenage years.
Why don't you attend parent meetings, Odd. You've got seven kids!
I think parent meetings are scary because ...
... it's so sentimental there.
How?
It's this ... I think that emotions should be directed outwards and not inwards.
Because inwards, it's so dark.
And with these child things, I have the impression that there's a lot of talk about inwards stuff.
That's difficult to be a part of, so I have avoided that.
My wife has done it excellently.
Do you like parent meetings?
No.
I can be really shy! I haven't been to many parent meetings over the years, but ...
But we usually have separate conversations.
I think it's quite difficult to be in a large group, I can get shy.
I tend to put on my head phones and pretend that I'm listening to music.
Before the meetings start.
So I still can hear what's happening, but then I won't get disrupted.
And you don't have to get to know all the other parents?
Yes. I think that small conversations are really difficult.
I often become too honest and too direct.
And then the atmosphere can become weird.
So you can relate to what Odd says about ...
... this social anxiety?
A lot of times, it feels like ...
It's an awkward situation for everyone.
Yes, it becomes ...
I like conversations in small groups.
I think it's difficult when it becomes too big.
There are also some men who join breathing exercises.
Together with the pregnant one.
Yes, before they give birth, when they're trying to learn how to breathe?
And I haven't been part of any breathing exercises.
No.
We all do what we can.
My father is extremely focused.
And ...
That's part of the point of doing this TV show, to get people to understand that.
That we're not talking about ...
Rembrandt may have painted 10 master pieces, but Odd may have painted 100.
And ...
People in the present time don't understand this.
That was generous?
No it's not generous, it's pretty factual.
Within my field, this is quite factual.
Those big words are not from me.
I'm not allowed to say that because I'm the son.
But ...
Odd, you've said that you're a person who complains a lot.
Yes, but I have to admit that I've lived a happy a life as a person is able to experience.
And the reason for that is that ...
I have a family, that Øde is part of ...
... who protect me in a fantastic way.
Especially my wife.
So ...
I've lived in a land of happiness, in a way.
I think you deserve an applause for that!
No!
Before we finish, I have to ask you ...
You've driven here from Helsingborg ...
... where you now live. You still live at home?
Yes. I live with my father and his pupils.
He found the house.
And there we could remove the whole floor.
And we almost got a cathedral up.
Extremely high up!
And it became really nice.
And you can see Denmark?
I can see all the way to Copenhagen.
And you can see that the earth is round, they way I have painted it many times.
So that is very dream-like.
Do you feel you've come full circle, now that you're back in your place of birth?
No, I think the graveyard is very beautiful ...
And I said to someone who was there once ...
... that it's so beautiful, the graveyard.
Those who lay there must have a wonderful time.
And he replied: «Ugh. Ugh.»
So I don't think that's the reason I went there.
That's nice to hear.
The headroom.
It was beautiful there!
Odd, Øde, thank you so much for being here today!